- When I watch this sequence, I love that
I still get emotional as he
becomes the fastest man alive.
- And one of the things
people don't realize
is that all the in-flight
dialogue was recorded in flight.
You feel it in the movie.
They're experiencing the G-forces.
They're having trouble breathing.
It puts you in the plane, it's amazing.
- One thing about this one for us
was we got to not only
make a cool sounding car,
but also treat it almost like a beast.
For the most part, what
you're hearing there
is actually a bottle
rocket just slowed down
from being one second long
to being 60 seconds long.
And then me on sampler just
kind of manipulating it
to give it the pitch rise
that I wanted it to have.
- Clarity is king, the whole
Way of Water is about a family,
it's about an emotional journey.
We were trying to make sure
that the story got told
in the most emotional and valuable way.
- Baz wanted a whirlwind of sound
because at this point in
the film in the 1950s,
it was a frightening and dangerous time
for the establishment
because at this point,
Elvis Presley shifted the
cultural landscape of America.
- We go to all the
extremes, light and dark,
loud and quiet, brutality
that doesn't hold back
to the delicate moments of devastation,
all the emotions that
the soldiers went through
in the story and in the war.